hi hi yeah we will appreciate all your
knowledge and things and I just went
through an episode with tachycardia and
I was in the hospital for several days
okay in point anything and congestive
heart failure as well and pitting edema
and okay well hitting a team that goes
along with congestive heart failure tell
me about this tachycardia have you ever
had that before I had about 20-some odd
years ago not long after I had my
mercury fillings renew and they put
aluminum up in there that I still have
that means to get gone okay how much you
weigh Kevin about right now and about
close to 190 okay any other issues any
diabetes high blood pressure I had the
high blood pressure as well and and my
why I mentioned tachycardia yeah okay
well the take your do you have any back
problems any back issues
yeah I have those all right I went
through a car roof when I was 16 car hit
me in a stopped car going about a
hundred miles an hour and I came through
the well and risking okay okay no need
you have any history of any asthma
bronchitis as a kid or any skin palms
eczema dermatitis arises no none of that
okay
all right Charmaine you there yeah okay
what do you think is going on with Kevin
well I think he has his problem is
really from pinched nerves in his back
yeah it's back problem squeezing the
roots of these spinal nerves to control
the rate and rhythm of the heart and you
get into a certain position bending over
getting out of bed too quick laying down
something you can get tachycardia which
can be called a tip atrial fibrillation
congestive heart those caused by
deficiency of a single vitamin how would
pressure can be caused by many things
and so what would you do our friend
kevin here from Argan personally I would
get Ahmad two healthy brain and heart
pack
I would add the gluco gel and then I
would add this house destructor Jill
wait a minute luca gels for the
musculoskeletal system how's that going
to help because because he's lost the
cartilage between his vertebrae on the
nerve that controls your hurt me go goes
through your dreams phone and it's
getting squeezed because he's lost
cartilage and he's shrunk in height
alright sharp what would you throw in
for the hello pressure well for the
blood pressure he needs to yellow the
daily classic the nice and plus and the
cardio strict okay get a plus tear and
kevin in charge is correct 190 pounds
you had one two of the healthy brain and
hard packs get two large bottles of the
luca jousting take 15 a day five at
breakfast five at lunch five at dinner
and that is to support manager pair
those discs in between the vertebrae so
you can push those vertebrae apart take
the pressure off of the spinal nerves
that control the heart rhythm and and
rate you want the these treads capsules
capital d like david - stress on three
of those twice a day
even three times a day it'll be two or
three bottles a month pull that off and
then for the blood pressure
char's exactly right you want the
ultimate daily classic tablets ultimate
three words ultimate daily classic
towers i'd go ahead and take three of
those twice a day or three three times a
day so it's either two or three of those
bottles per month depending on cost for
you we don't put too much pressure and
wallet and then you can throw in two
bottles a month of the ultimate niacin
plastic to those twice a day and then
the ultimate cardio sticks when two
boxes are at a month take one of
breakfast warm dinner time go in boxes a
thirty and the ultimate daily classic
the ultimate cardio sticks and the
ultimate niacin plus are all designed to
support healthy blood pressure and
support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries it's imperative to stay
away from the bad stuff too fried foods
the processed meats the oils of gluten
all the things that inflame the arteries
and certainly can aggravate and then
sugar too because sugar
aggravates the these efficiencies that
results in congestive heart cooler so
I'm gonna stay away from juices and
fruit and honey and molasses Nogami
syrup and that kind of stuff call us in
two weeks
we're gonna want to know your pulse your
blood pressure and so forth